[Musique]
alors que ce matin on visite à l'hôpital
de la salpêtrière à paris le président
de la république emmanuel macron a
déclaré on a devant nous créer une
épidémie carré ça suppose de s'organiser
à chaque étape sans doute différemment
on va devoir le premier ministre a tenté
de nuancer ses propos inquiétants il y a
lieu ni d'avoir peur ni d'être
négligents pourtant les chiffres ne
cessent de progresser notamment chez nos
voisins italiens qui font passer à une
épidémie de taille en quelques jours le
bilan est passé de zéro à plus de 650
cas de personnes contaminées dont 37 se
trouve actuellement en soins intensifs
17 personnes sont déjà décédées
un bilan qui s'alourdit d'heure en heure
et qui inquiète beaucoup car les allées
et venues avec l'italie sont quotidiens
et les risques de propagation du virus
sont énormes
alors qu'un deuxième mort sur le
territoire français a été annoncée hier
ce soir olivier ferrand le ministre de
la santé a annoncé que le nombre de
personnes contaminées en france est
désormais de 38 en chine 78 mille
personnes contaminées ont été recensés à
ce jour et 2744 ont perdu la vie de son
côté le japon a décidé de fermer
temporairement toutes les écoles
élémentaires par mesure de précaution
pour le directeur de l' oms l'institut
mondiale pour la santé il n'est pas trop
tard mais il faut faire vite
nous sommes à un moment décisif si vous
agissez maintenant de manière agressive
vous pouvez endiguer ce coronavirus mon
conseil est d'agir rapidement un virus
qui tétanisent les populations du monde
entier en attente de réponse forte et
efficace
on va voir lady rumeurs sur le corps un
virus qui sortent de plus en plus c'est
un vrai faux merci à thomas d'être là
bien sûr journaliste réalisateur chinois
ici vrai ou faux nous sommes protégés du
coronavirus lorsque nous sommes vaccinés
contre la grippe
florence cassez était faux et bien
plutôt faut masser photo marianne
entendu ces stries c'est ça c'est cécile
chaix news qui veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas vaccinés contre la lave et c'est une
fête nous bien sûr ça puisque aucun
vaccin n'a été trouvé pour l'instant
partout dans le monde les laboratoires
travaillent mais il va falloir des mois
pour en trouver un
selon l'institut pasteur qui travaillent
sur le vaccin contre la rougeole le
vaccin contre le coronavirus ne sera pas
disponible avant l'automne 2021 d'ici là
les pies d'amis l'épidémie sera sûrement
passé comme n'existe ni vaccin ni
médicament contre le coronavirus la
prise en charge consiste à traiter les
symptômes surtout donc c'est faux si
vous êtes vacciné contre la grippe
bien sûr vous pourrez avoir le
coronavirus vrai ou faux la grippe
saisonnière tue plus que le coronavirus
en france
alors question qui est un petit peu con
plus compliqué que ça la grille qu'une
traditionnelle risque de faire plus de
morts que le coronavirus mais par
rapport au pourcentage de gens qui
seraient touchés par la grippe
eh bien on va voir avec le coronavirus
une un taux de mortalité beaucoup plus
important et sarah et donc il faut il
faut bien mesurer la différence statut
mais vous voyez quelque chose cette
histoire montre bien quelque chose c'est
que c'est dans le détail que se trouvent
souvent la vérité ou le mensonge
exactement parce qu'en vrai en le temps
de l'expliquer tout le monde nous dit
qu'à grippe tue plus que le corps d'un
virus en france alors c'est vrai en
nombre mais en vrai on pourcentage les
coronavirus tue plus
on meurt plus du corona virus de la
grippe exactement aujourd'hui soit là et
mes amis parce qu'avec beaucoup de gens
étaient contaminés là ça me plaît de
faire frémir les actes eux mans 1 pour
mille
il y en a il ya une personne sur 1000
qui meurent de la grippe
il ya une personne sur son qui meurent
du coroner énorme vrai ou faux les
dizaines de millions de masques
commandés par le ministère pourront être
achetés en pharmacie par tout le monde
vrai ou faux ces comptes ont scellé ce
matin
qu'est ce qui est faux mais c'est faux
mais je crois que ça nous rappelle aussi
l'histoire du virus h5n1 où il y avait
la grippe à des normes eu peu polémique
sur le fait que la ministre de la santé
roselyne bachelot à l'époque avait à
acheter une quantité très importante un
vaccin et charriés par l'eau lui avait
reproché
oui moi je vais vous dire un truc je
suis content qu'elle ait acheté des
vaccins et
je n'ai aucun problème avec tout ça je
préfère ça pense prévenir que guérir
exactement c'est très bien c'est le très
bonne formule non mais alors puisqu'elle
a expliqué la secrétaire jocelyne vite
offre jocelyne wittevrongel elle a un
nom de dominer râle la secrétaire
générale de la fédération des syndicats
pharmaceutiques
elle a expliqué que les 15 millions de
masques ffp2 qui vont être déstocker
seront uniquement réservé aux
professionnels de la santé a expliqué ça
chez jean marc morandini ce matin
quatrième vrai ou faux vrai ou faux les
billets de banques doivent être nettoyés
à cause du coronavirus vrai ou faux
malheureusement c'est ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire en chine afin d'essayer
de prévenir l'expansion de la pandémie
je crois que dans ces cas là il faut
bien comprendre quelque chose le
principe de précaution prévenir movéo
prévenir que guérir
bien sûr très important et je crois que
il y aura peut-être des démarches un
petit peu exagéré mais on a toujours
mieux derrière ce que ces démarches sont
entreprises
alors donc vous rendez compte ça c'est
un vrai scoop sur les billets dont on ne
dira nous cyril on doit on doit nettoyer
nos billets tout ça quand vous n'avez
pas comment elle est encore là en fait
c'est il se trouve que dans la ville de
oignies les banques sont en train de
mettre en place exactement un système
ans en chine la banque centrale a décidé
de mettre en quarantaine tous les
billets usagés afin de les nettoyer
le but bien sûr éviter le risque de
contamination car les billets de banques
passent de main en main et transporte
beaucoup de microbes et de bactéries
ça c'est une info c'est incroyable ça
cadrait ou faux c'est le sens concerne
contact assez part du champion ça se
fait ou faux la bière corona souffre du
coronavirus ya je pense que tout le
monde est venu depuis deux semaines des
photos montages sur internet montraient
des dunes
bière corona face à tout un tas d'autres
bières qui était je crois que la marque
de toutes les manières a subi un impact
négatif en termes de communication donc
on voit ça à jouer contre eux exactement
c'est pas une vanne puisque depuis
quelques semaines le nom du virus qui
portent prêt porte préjudice à la marque
1 1 obtenu de nombreuses recherches sur
google portait sur le virus de la bière
et la popularité de la marque est en
chute libre
alors que près de 80% des américains on
avait une image positive fin 2009
ils ne sont plus que 50 % c'est dire la
part d'américains autant acheter de la
bière corona dans les prochains jours
est tombé à 5 %
c'est incroyable je vous dis brand et
coûteux les policiers sanctionnés la
tête ça pouvait pas s'appeler le chrono
pour vivre enfin quand les supporters de
trump vont découvrir que la corona ces
mexicains eux
vrai ou faux manger de l'ail protège de
l'infection alors j'en ai ramené un peu
à bercy frottez vous bien fort de l'aïe
sur le fond sur les oreilles mais non
c'est un énorme mensonge c'est ce qu'on
a vu sur les raisons de ce qu'on fait ce
qu'on va lire mais vous savez cette
histoire ça nous rappelle quelque chose
une femme aux états unis l'année
dernière son enfant est malade le
médecin lui prescrit du tamiflu
c'est un médicament contre contre la
corde à lérida brume et du coup qu'est
ce qu'elle fait cette dame elle rentre
chez elle avec son enfant elle passe pas
par la pharmacie elle se met sur un
groupe facebook sur les vaccins les
médicaments et on lui dit non non il
faut que tu m delahaye que tu mettes de
la pommade à ton gamin ça va aller il
est mort trois jours un prénom très bien
comprendre quelque chose tous ces
mensonges qui circulent en permanence
sur internet
ça fait des morts bien sûr 1-4 les faits
que nous cf
c'est très grave alors je vous le dis on
trouve plein de mauvaises mains de
miracle mais bien sûr il faudrait faire
fodé faire très attention parce qu'on a
vu bonne nouvelle le virus coronado yuan
peut être guérie par un bol d'eau die
fraîchement bouillie un vieux docteur
chinois a prouvé son efficacité c'est
n'importe quoi voilà et donc lie n'est
que n'écoutait pas ça c'est n'importe
quoi
7e vrai ou faux la prochaine rumeur fait
le tour d'internet depuis hier a été
relayée par notre ami pascal praud ce
matin selon l' oms donc l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
la fellation serait moins contagieuses
qu'une poignée de main ça veut dire
qu'il vaut mieux cette appellation pour
se dire bonjour qu'une fois les mains
voilà on a moins de l'eia on a bien la
session alors du prêt alors il ya pascal
praud regarder qui est tombé dans le
panneau et pascal claverie l'annoncé
conviendra info est ce que c'est vrai ou
pas son préféré quand il permet de
garder une parente il faut le dire c'est
manu portet et j'ai entendu cette
information absolument incroyable la
fellation et moins contagieuse que se
serrer la main
donc c'est pas c'est pas vrai que ça me
semblerait pas absurde puisque la salle
avec un antiseptique son coeur avec elle
dans la semaine c'est pourtant qu il
faut c'est fou cette rue normes toutes
reprises et est une question à poser aux
précédentes invités oui mais c'est
n'importe quoi bien sûr vrai ou faux
kate et williams kate et william bien
sûr e catégories sont concernées de près
par le coronavirus c'est vrai que pas eu
directement mais quatre écoliers de
l'école où sont scolarisés leurs enfants
à londres ils ont été mis en quarantaine
car soupçonnée d'avoir été contaminée
par le virus la famille royale n'a
toujours pas réagi vrai ou faux le corps
d'un virus a été créé par la cia alors
parce que c'est aussi des spectacles ce
qu'on fera l'écho aurions dû à la non en
fait c'est si vous voulez mais moi j'ai
si je suis sur ce plateau c'est aussi
parce que je serai beaucoup sur ces
questions parce que j'ai inventé un faux
complots pour coincer les complotistes
en 2015
on avait inventé l'idée que la cia avait
inventé le sida alors été attaqués aux
cubains et donc pourquoi on avait
inventé ça parce que ça allait marcher à
l'époque on a pu coincer tout un tas de
gens je crois qu'il faut bien comprendre
quelque chose y ait une souche du
coronavirus qui a déjà été détecté une
autre forme de maladie qui a été
détectée breveté en 2003 et donc des
documents scientifiques de cette époque
ont été manipulés sur internet pour nous
faire croire que le coronavirus existait
depuis des années qu il accorde donc
inventé par une puissance étrangère et
dans ce cas là la cia ça marche pas mal
on aurait pu dire les sionistes dessus
sinon se fait en général sur les
théories du complot et voilà c'est un
peu là dessus qu'on va en garder assez
un peu partout vrai ou faux les matches
de ligue 1 donc les matches devant la
devant doute de ce week-end se joueront
ce week-end donc vrai ou faux et vrai
mais ça fayette fouet pour l'instant
tous les matches de ligue 1 sont
maintenant la ligue de football
professionnel qui organisent les matches
a communiqué aujourd'hui la lfp suit la
situation avec la plus grande attention
à ce stade nous n'avons reçu aucune
nouvelle instruction des pouvoirs
publics si des mesures sont prises nous
les appliquerons et nous nous adapterons
nous adapterons le match de rugby
irlande italie a été annulée et le match
de football entre la juventus et l'inter
milan se jouera lui à huis clos où je
vous le dis donc ça recommence à offrir
clip et voilà tiens vrai ou faux les
émissions de télé sont en danger à cause
du coronavirus et j'en oublie c'est vrai
c'est vraiment puisque ea même voilà
laurent bignolas ce présentateur télé
mâtin a été écarté de l'émission après
un séjour en italie nous ici on a très
très peur je vous le dis que les gens
doivent rester chez eux puisque ces sont
des émissions en public
donc forcément je vous le dis c'est
c'est une catastrophe
vrai ou faux le coronavirus a fait
perdre plus de 100 millions d'euros
grands groupes français
c'est beaucoup plus c'est que c'est un
milliard c'est incroyable c'est énorme
que ce soit dans les secteurs de
l'industrie du commerce et du tourisme
quelques grands groupes ont estimé leurs
pertes pour le premier trimestre 2009 1
seb le groupe seb 250 millions en un
trimestre en faire schneider electric
300 millions danone 100 millions air
france klm 150 à 200 millions d'euros de
pertes
voilà je vous le dis au premier
trimestre ça va être avoir des
répercussions économiques viables